we have this idea of a machine having or
a network card or Wi-Fi card having a
MAC address which I understand to be a
unique address to that different not
necessary that device but certainly to
that network interfaces that's probably
the best word for is it so the question
is why do we need IP addresses we've got
MAC addresses
okay so that it's an interesting
question is because they do different
things I'd saved from with the clear
bouncer to a MAC address looks something
like six bytes beneath net MAC address
there are some details about the first
few bits at the start of this which can
be used to indicate things like this is
multicast and they can broadcast a
couple of things and then you've
essentially got these indicate the what
you can think of it as the manufacturer
so you apply to the standards body
I think it's selectively to get a block
you pay them some money and you get a
block and then you convince your own MAC
addresses from that and then these would
refer normally to the station on the
network on the Ethernet so I give you a
fairly big address space you can address
quite a lot in 65 so it used to be the
case that these were burnt into the
hardware of the Ethernet card back in
the day when it was all you know
physical things on physical wires
there'd be something on the card which
have this hard hard coded into in that
in the hardware nowadays and nowadays I
mean for several years particularly with
Wi-Fi it's been possible to set this
through software in many cases so you
can't in fact guarantee there's a
one-to-one mapping between the network
card which is used to be what it
identified and the MAC address for it so
you can change the MAC address only
given network our particular in Wi-Fi
it's one of the reasons why spoofing on
Wi-Fi is so much is actually easier than
people think
some people think on the other hand an
IP address it's a full byte number in
hex that might be something like that
I'm not gonna try and translate that to
decimal in my head an example of a
decimal one would be 10.0.0.0 notation
these are bytes each of these goes from
0 to 255 when you have Hollywood doing
films the number of times that CSI is a
particular example of this as well the
number of times that people will do
trace routes and other such things to IP
addresses that start in seven
something of this is completely minions
yeah possibly maybe it's been done
deliberately I like will be nice to
think it was done deliberately so you've
got these two different address formats
and they're doing two different things
so this use would be used to identify
the frames for you on the internet that
you were connected to physically
connected to so for example on the
Ethernet frame this is why you start out
with the destination address then you
have the source address and then you
have a protocol field and it's because
the first bits that hit the interface
card should be the destination address
because the card needs to make a
decision should I receive this or not or
should I just need to start ignoring it
this conversation is to do yeah when you
go back to the first versions of
Ethernet you'd have Ethernet cards
sitting on an Ethernet they'd have they
were called vampire taps coming off them
I think that was the first version of
this and then you'd have a much thicker
cable connecting them and it was called
a vampire tap because literally you
screwed it into the coax it broke
through the sheath and hit the core in
the middle and that was what connected
the car to the cable so you'd have
multiple stations electrically connected
same physical line and so there'd be
signals passing up and down this line
and each station even though should I
listen to this signal or not do I need
to start receiving it turning into bits
passing up to the computer into the
memory etc you want to make that
decision early because back in the day
things were expensive and things were
slow and so you put the destination bits
first and then the card can make a
decision very early do I need to keep
listening and put this into memory or
can I just ignore it and it kind of
carries through into technology even
though it doesn't matter so much if you
look at my pee address then the first
feels the well Ashley the first feels
you get you've got a version you've got
ahead of length and such like but the
first feels in address terms you get the
source and the destination interestingly
still the way around because by the time
you've got this stage it's maybe a bit
less important and you're gonna have to
do quite a lot more thinking anyway
about the thing about the packet coming
in so you don't need to make this very
fast decision to decide to ignore it the
other thing about IP addresses is so
Ethernet starts out with the idea that
you've got a bunch of stations attached
to a particular cable IP is with the
idea that you've got multiple networks
with different things in them maybe
different technologies and you want to
start inter connecting between these
networks
so it's a much bigger thing to start
with you're trying to build a much
bigger Network than you're thinking
about when you're building an Ethernet
where you've got generally things quite
local so these this is known as a local
area network a LAN nowadays you think of
different sizes of this so you might
think of a metropolitan area network or
a man you might think of a wide area
network or a wham but it's a much bigger
network and so you've got a lot more
information in some sense to encode if
you try using MAC addresses they have no
structure
other than this manufacturer and their
station ID and so if you want to look up
what to do when you've got a map that
gotta be that frame that's arrived and
what you should weigh should send it you
just need a big table of everything
which on the Internet is completely
infeasible that's part of it you've got
no structure to it with IP address you
can do prefix matching so you can
represent blocks of IP addresses with a
single entry so you no longer have to
have a table with two to the 32 about 4
billion entries in it to make a decision
what to do you match it against the
entries that you've got which cover
ranges and so because it's got more
structure embedded in it you can sort of
compress that information and you can
make that look a process quicker and you
can help it to scale out more and that's
why ipv4 has this ability to lose global
network whereas it would be quite
difficult to run a really global
Ethernet just relying on standard
Ethernet style protocols to do that
wouldn't work as well and that's why
then i PB six and has one of the reasons
got this bigger address space so it's
got 128 bits per address rather than 32
bits progress gives you more addresses
but then you you have this ability
because they're structured you've got
this ability to compress them down so
you don't have to have to 220 528
entries in each ITV security because
that's a lot so the IP address is a bit
more like a street address okay you can
break it down into city streets it would
be hard to find that house from the
phone number and therefore I'm just
having a huge list of phone numbers it's
really not useful yeah via knowledge
it's not that far away I think and it's
only the idea that you've got a
structure in the address and structure
that allows you to compress the entries
and allows you to make decisions from
far away as well so so commonly in an IP
network some of these routers will have
a complete table so they'll have I think
currently we're running at about just
something over five
thousand entries in that table even
given the fact that you can compress
these down and express ranges rather
than having to express each address
individually but some of these Reuters
particularly there you know roots in the
middle of a network may not for whatever
reason so they may have default roots
for example so it may be the case that
you've got two hundred thousand entries
and then you've got one entry which
covers everything else and so that's the
default route if you're on a smaller
network that is connected to a much
bigger backbone Network quite commonly
you'll end up with you've got some
addresses for the things that are inside
your network and the things your
customers connected directly to you and
then you might have a default route
which says everything else that's not
one of your own customers goes up to
whoever provides you with service and so
you can sometimes have interesting cases
where if for example this smaller
network is multihomed
as they call it so it's connected to
multiple bigger networks and a mistake
happens in the configuration you end up
being used as a three route for some
reason and this is then well it's not
good for you because you're now carrying
probably a lot more traffic than you can
code with and it's not good for anybody
else who's connecting to these two large
networks because now their traffic has
taken this completely unnecessary hop
going further than these two taking on
that needs to do to get there perhaps
going through a bottleneck getting
slowed down to get there so it's
generally it's a bad thing exactly yeah
and if you make a mistake that route
suddenly becomes visible to the Sat Nav
right and then suddenly all the H TVs go
really fast to go that way it looks like
it should be really fast about that way
and in practicing one because now
they're all part of it
so what have I done have done a sorting
of the data and the approach I've done
is something based on similarity
measures I'm document 4 has 18 miles and
5 horses and document 5 is only about
the word mind not that horses and so the
first thing you would do